[Applause]
look he's got a republican tie on
laughs
oh this is fantastic thank you everybody
sit down sound please
it's fantastic to stand before you and
see all my friends out here
and the opportunity to say thank you the
opportunity to say thank you this is a
big deal but before we get into it why
are we here at Rancho and so we kicked
off this
campaign what 15 months ago it seems
like 10 years ago to me
but 15 months ago because this is where
I graduated and you and during the
process we were talking about me being
the education Governor moving forward
and I think it's important for a lot of
people who've lost faith in the
education system especially public
schools that we bring it back home
and have an understanding where we need
to go as a state to breed success moving
forward is as a state and it boils down
to education
and where is principal Delgado where did
she go
she's sitting way back there everybody
give her a round of applause
and the education superintendent Jesus
Jara is right up here up front thank you
Jesus
so he looked at my speech to make sure I
didn't have any spelling errors and
everything that goes along with it but
um
without further Ado let's get let's get
along with it
um this is just overwhelming to see you
all sitting out here and it's it's
fantastic so thank you
um well first let me start by saying
thank you that's what the speech says
[Applause]
well thank you to the great people in
Nevada for believing in our campaign
thank you for my Incredible family
for believing in me
and obviously I'll introduce them here
shortly
and thank you for my tireless staff
volunteers and supporters for believing
in our mission
and for never ever giving up
we would not be here today without you
from the bottom of my heart thank you
it's moving to be here today to deliver
these remarks at Rancho High School my
alma mater
not only did I I graduated I graduated
this individual right here Bobby Ellis
he didn't
but he was successful anyway but good
job Bobby
not only did I graduate years ago but
Rancho is also where I announced my
candidacy
to be the next governor in Nevada just
15 months ago
in my travels across the state I heard
from voters from all walks of life
and you know what they said they all
said the same thing Joe please help turn
our state around before it's too late
the urgency in their voice voices I will
never forget
so this Victory is for them
today marks A New Beginning it confirms
the new brand of leadership
is on the March
hey Pete how you doing buddy yeah
it's a win for parents who want to have
a voice in their child's education
it's a win for families who want a safer
community
and it's a win for small business owners
Pete
to paraphrase Ronald Reagan's 1981
inaugural address
it will require a best effort and our
willingness to believe in ourselves and
to believe in our capacity to form great
Deeds to believe that together with
God's help we can and we will resolve
the problems which now confront us
after all
why shouldn't we believe that because we
are nevadans
thank you
the real winners today are Republicans
Democrats and independents who believe
like I do in a more sensible more
realistic more responsible and more
accountable state government
on Friday I took a call from governor
sislak who was gracious and offered his
support
I thanked him and we pledged to work
together to complete a smooth transition
I want to take a moment to thank my wife
Donna
foreign
Morgan
[Applause]
and Lacey
and our newly minted grandchild
Theodore Theodore
I want to thank them for their love and
support without them this would have
never been possible so thank you very
much
I would also like to acknowledge the
hundreds and hundreds of friends across
the state that made phone calls
knocked doors and showed up at events
you helped me
you hope made you helped make the
difference
in addition Don and I were so very proud
of our campaign team our volunteers and
our donors in each of our 17 counties
please know that we were incredibly
grateful for your dedication and your
support
it's an experience we'll carry with us
for the rest of our lives
and we are enriched by knowing you
and what you did for this campaign so
thank you
a special thanks to our campaign chair
Mark Hutchinson who's unfortunately not
here today he's in Virginia but can we
give him a round of applause
our finance chair Dallas Hahn
is Dallas here today
[Applause]
well I'm sure he's watching on TV
campaign manager mattresso Matt
communications director Elizabeth Ray
stand up
she had probably the hardest job because
I tend to have a little bit of
Tourette's
and I tend to have a sometimes
inappropriate responses and she was able
to clean that up for me so I appreciate
that Elizabeth
foreign
my political director Faith Jones
and two of the most instrumental folks
two of the most uh influential folks and
me personally and this community and the
Republican Party
Ryan Irwin and Mike Slinger
where did Mike Go
where are you Mike
he won't ever see look he always stands
in the shadows
he won't take acknowledgment but thank
you guys thank you so much
words cannot adequately describe the
depth of our gratitude for your guidance
for two years Don and I crisscross the
state we met tens of thousands of
veterans who were deeply invested in the
future of Nevada
this message is for them now that the
election is over we must set aside our
differences and come together as
nevadans
to work toward a common goal to building
a stronger economy and a healthier and
safer Nevada
we must bring back common sense to
decision making
let me tell you this no matter who you
are
where you're from or who you voted for I
am ready to listen to you work for you
and earn your trust
I proudly served our country in the
United States Army and have dedicated my
life in protecting communities as a
police officer
and as the sheriff and now humbly as
your next governor
as your next Governor my Administration
will expand school choice and make
school safety a priority
fix the broken state agencies
create safer streets by eliminating soft
on crime laws
[Applause]
get our economy back on track so we
don't have to pay the price for bad
decisions coming out of Washington D.C
and my Administration will never stop
listening to you
my fellow Nevadas it's time it's our
time
in closing I will always level with the
voters in Nevada we may not agree on
every issue but I know that I will work
very hard to make you very proud to be
at nevadan
thanks Jerry
and know this too we will commit the
time it takes to bring our state
together and bring writing a new chapter
of Nevada history
hold on a little more a little more I
appreciate the pause
just we're getting there I'm sorry
to our supporters to our volunteers and
to all the abandons we're in this
together you have my word that I'll
assist on meeting on Common Ground armed
with new ideas and driven by discipline
to succeed
and we will succeed because we are
nevadans
and from the bottom of my heart I
sincerely thank the voters of Nevada for
the trust you have placed in me
it is the single greatest honor of my
life
and although I won't be sworn in until
January Our Journey Begins now
right
so I leave you with this thank you
and God bless you and God bless Nevada
[Applause]
so uh as a run of agenda I will not be
answering any questions for the Press I
will provide opportunity here in the
future to address any questions you may
have in full transparency which I intend
to lead by
uh but more importantly thank you all
for taking the time out of your day to
show your support and thank you for all
the support you've given me for the last
15 months and you know what
for the last 23 years
thank you
and please please do not be offended
when you have attempted to reach out to
me in the last couple days and I have
been slow to respond
because mysteriously I have a bunch of
new friends
so I uh
no no no but all my true friends I know
who you are and I know who is in this
for the right reasons and each and every
one of you are and I hope to God I do
not let you down thank you
[Applause]